you said Lord of the Rings don't be
ashamed about being a massive [ __ ]
nerd that's okay Lord of the Rings is
there a particular part of Lord of the
Rings that you'd like its focus on no
can I even like Tom Bombadil or
something yeah your geek he's not in the
movies only in the books okay Lord of
the Rings what the Rings is fine in
general I like that let's go to this
side if you guys are hit what you want
to hear a rapper climbing the corporate
ladder yeah yeah do it I love that we
which wrote Lord of the Rings climbing
the corporate ladder let's get real
Chris
none of this fantasy [ __ ] okay okay
there's work to be done not you know a
thousand pages to be written about elves
climbing the corporate ladder Lord of
the Rings if you are in the kind of the
front middle segment of the room would
you yeah that was just slur I'm so sorry
I I think I deciphered because I think
you're a you from London yeah I'm using
show so the lady said why are buttons so
big on cardigans if you don't know what
to cardigan is America's is like a
sweater that is kind of cut down it's
like a shirt made of sheep is that right
and quite often the buttons will be
bigger than the whole so you have to
kind of like yeah yeah is that is that
what you're getting at good good
British people have an innate
understanding of each other
what a very British grave just like by a
button so big on cardigans my gosh my
gosh good golly good honey
that's weird isn't it my British accent
is really [ __ ] so okay climbing the
corporate ladder Lord of the Rings wire
buttons so big on cardigans that's a
brilliant suggestion thank you so much
back at the room what you want to rap
about what one sec so someone said
banana which is a food so unacceptable
you said you say feudal feudal corgis oh
I know what corgis are but as in you
mean fuelers in the feudal system yes
okay well you're so passionate about
this corgis and a punk [ __ ] [ __ ] it up
feudal corgis again if you don't know
what the feudal system is I do not have
time to explain it but figure out feudal
corgis wild cardigan buns so big
climbing the corporate ladder Lord the
Rings let's get one final one and this
can come from wherever just make it like
a very nice one you said pyramids you
said bars and what do you say you see
puh-leeze at pyramids and bars
okay well we'll combine that for pyramid
bars we'll figure out what that is
um cool lovely people of the Comedy
Cellar I'm so excited for this now I'm
gonna live out my dream it's gonna be
amazing don't be a rapper and into a rap
for you guys about climbing the
corporate ladder about Lord of the Rings
about Wyatt cardigan funds so big about
funeral corgis into our pyramid bods and
don't worry it's not me anywhere near as
the trusses as [ __ ] as you're expecting
it to be cool red can we drop that beat
and how we do
see maybe a little less loud in my ear
ah I am so thrilled for this this is
amazing we're gonna start with yours
this sounds great yeah it's hard as a
lady and I always feel how you climb the
corporate ladder when you wear in high
heels
you're like Mario saying let's go
because you gotta remove you still let
so it's like all the men have greased
the wrongs they stand there with the
money saying Sam well huh you wanna rise
up well here you go but there's a glass
ceiling for the CEO you can't get into
the top of the company when you're
running the logs and your skirt is Mindy
you got a Swifter trousers to get into
the boardroom Lou but all the white guys
they're like there's no room you've got
to leave or make us a sandwich men big
bunch of pigs don't understand it I
don't even like them I wanna dig itself
I go to Mordor I've got a whole army of
elves a gift for the guys a little talk
you gotta [ __ ] those guys up together
all odds and are a high they're more an
ugly guy who Peter Jackson he ain't so
high and he cleared it with no ifs or
buts but Jesus Christ how long's
directors cup it's like three half hours
in the film sunlight stop it no one
gives a [ __ ] about all the other hobbits
raised in the shower
killing all it with a wealth my favorite
one Ian McKellen as downed elf Gandalf
the White and Gandalf the Grey in real
life Ian McKellen his day that's not a
judgment it's just a fact I'm where it's
we're not [ __ ] young wood burns on
the back if I was a haberdasher wise my
goal make a cardigan with adequate sized
balls why are the stitches so small it's
like I can't get the buns fit in the
tall it tears in these stretches each
time I move it if you are a fabric man
improve it I said man
and then fabric person when I'm in Cairo
and I've got a thirst on I look dear and
then I look for [ __ ] the whole this
pyramid has got a great bar I walk in
through the door in the room I'm getting
[ __ ] late into saqar moods - and I'm
like give me a shot of all your whiskey
I know it's mummified so it's Panna
risky I drink all the Scotch whisky
first a slake my thirst even though is
probably cursed built up there by the
Jews
apparently the EgyptAir roam a them dude
then Moses let them far away no wine for
these guys because you when they say
last then one guy will adore me if I
drop fire about feudal corgis yeah you
gotta call be right at the top the king
of the dogs never gonna stop other
little slave Porky's they made soup
saying why is he the king he's [ __ ]
Snoop with the little legs little dogs
with the big heads the Queen in the
throne room uses them to rest legs
she's like feudal Corey stay down the
Queen's on top because she wears that
crown yep
[Applause]